ich gehöre jetzt nicht zu denen die zum
lachen in den keller gehen ein scherz
beiseite das herz scherz beiseite ein
scherz aber
ich bin manchmal einen scherz ist ja
auch okay
ja bitte
hallo hier sehr herzlich willkommen wir
haben frische dabei und vielleicht den
einen oder anderen guten witz aber ich
weiß man wie also ich glaube es na ja
wir versuchen die nase alter werden wir
schon hin klar ich denke auf dem platz
es ist eigentlich ok für sie wie wir
hier mit dem auto oder sollen wir die
hemden lieber in die hose stecken nie
dass das ist total okay es kommt
gelegentlich auch mal vor das ist auch
bei der hose tragen ein was ist denn da
also wenn sie ganz verrückt ja wir
freuen uns jetzt so sein zum
arbeitsfrühstück wir sehr gut da wäre ja
mal gespannt weil sie mit einiges
fleischwurst
und veganen schinken spicker was ist das
liebes und veganer schinken spieker ich
weiß nicht also hab mich da noch nicht
so richtig ran getraut ich habe die
sorge es kommt schlecht an im wahlkreis
aber
im urlaub ist ja aber ich fänd ich gönne
jedem seinen vegan schinken später aber
ich es dann doch lieber richtige wurst
das ist auch okay da bin ich vielleicht
ein bisschen rustikaler anlagen müssen
wir machen es mal ja wir können wir
können's machen heute die premiere
heißen wir mal ehrlich so richtig
natürlich sieht es nicht aus
also ich probier das jetzt hier mal
amtlich also grüße an die veganen
schinken freunde
man kommt durch
[Gelächter]
da kommt ja nur der name team motta
della du alter zerstört naja
jeder essen der will ich bin ja nicht
hier wie von den grünen dass ich allen
leuten vorschreiben was sie essen soll
und was nicht deswegen weil man das
gerne mag sie sind wirklich nicht wie
von den grünen dass gerade das ist ja
das kann man wirklich
sagen was habt ihr denn noch schön ist
er ja auch sonst haben wir noch hier
also bärchen wurst sind ja auch jäger
deswegen finde ich auch ist doch auch
gut wenn man lebensmittel auch auf
wertschätzt und so das gehört auch mal
ein zweites kind habe ich auch gerne mal
so es ist ja auch okay aber haben als
vor drei monaten
das sind ja da müsst ihr euch noch ein
haben die jetzt dann müsst ihr euch
jetzt noch entscheiden ob es vor drei
monaten war oder vor 30 jahren irgendwo
ist immer es war ja der ist gespannt ja
wir wollen ein bisschen über die cdu
auch reden alle reden gerade von der
modernisierung der cdu werden sie das
noch verhindern dann will ich gar nicht
nein sondern ich finde die cdu
entwickelt sich in der sehr gute
richtung in den letzten monaten was sind
die großen themen auf die die cdu jetzt
setzen sollte oder anders gefragt von
welchen themen würden sie sich
aktienoptionen holen der war natürlich
auch sehr gehört das war jetzt wirklich
absehbar muss man sagen auf den muss man
ja so war das muss ich
haben sie ihm vor dem dreh
aktienoptionen angeboten dass er sich
auf ihre seite schick
ja ja nein scherz beiseite das ganze
thema hat mich sehr geärgert auch damals
ich mich vor allem über mich selbst ist
es auch okay das gehört gehört auch dazu
aber der blick enthält eine ernsthafte
frage was sind jetzt die wichtigen
themen manche haben gesagt ja wenn jetzt
der friedrich merz parteivorsitzender
wird dann ist hier irgendwie zurück in
die vergangenheit das ist überhaupt
nicht der fall er hat ja auch diese neue
moderne brille friedrich merz aber sie
haben auch eine ähnliche oder auch
bewährt haben sie ihn beraten ich finde
ich finde die brille steht ihm gut und
ich finde es ist auch bezeichnend wieder
das dann manches mal ein während
debattiert wird über eine neue brille
von friedrich merz als über eine gute
rede aber das ist auch okay so ist es
halt
bei uns geht es ja da ist auch wichtig
deswegen machen wir haben deswegen bin
ich ja auch in diesem akademischen
seminar über inhalte wir haben halt
nichts modernes gefunden was ich gesucht
habe aber der friedrich merz ist jemand
der eine breite akzeptanz auch in der
bevölkerung da geht's auch nicht nur
irgendwie ums alter sondern ich finde
einfach um die ansichten ja und ich
finde auch die daher gibt es viele dinge
die da irgendwie auch als falsche labels
versehen werden also friedrich merz ist
jemand der auch ein modernes bild hat er
wenn irgendwelche einzelnen zitate
rausgekramt von
1998 und dann glaubt man der mensch hat
sich nicht verändert es ist nicht wahr
ja oder auch letztes jahr war es glaube
ich als er da über jens spahn schwuler
kampfkandidat auch das ja auch nach neun
jahre also da muss man aber auch mal
ernsthaft sagen natürlich ist es immer
so das passiert auch wenn man als
politiker viel in den medien ist dass
man da auch gelegentlich mal
kommunikativ daneben liegt und die
haltung aber da ist friedlich mehr als
jemand der eine ganz offene normale
haltung hat also friedrich merz können
wir so festhaltend ist jemand eine
offene haltung hat aber gelegentlich
kommunikativ mal daneben ach quatsch
also es ist also da habe ich den
eindruck gibt es halt viele die
friedlich mehr hat es auch bewusst
sozusagen in die ecke der
rückwärtsgewandtheit schieben wollen
mich auch und dagegen kann man sich dann
aber auch wer außerdem sind ja die
zahlen erst mal ernüchternd also die
cdu-mitglieder sind ja im schnitt 60,8
jahre alt könnten sie sich vorstellen
aus der cdu ausgetreten um den schnitt
ein bisschen zu senken ja da ist wieder
das sah ja da ist er wieder die
inkonsistenz ist ein bisschen nach erst
vor drei monaten in der schule jetzt in
anderen vereinen hat beide seiten über
das festival na gut sie sind jetzt seit
einem halben jahr in der zweiten reihe
cdu in der opposition wie fühlt sich das
an naja opposition ist schon wichtig
weil man muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
ohne opposition ist die demokratie keine
demokratie aber es ist so schön war
schon geil na ja es hat es hat alles vor
nachteile ich muss mal sagen opposition
heißt ja auch manchmal die regierung mit
fiesen fragen mit unangenehmen
nachfragen mit piesacken zu ärgern und
das ist auch wichtig also ja nur sondern
wir haben ein paar tricks lassen fast
noch ein bisschen inhaltlicher aber in
die richtung sehen ist und deswegen
braucht zu uns aber ja ich so sehr wie
werden rausgeworfen ihr werdet noch
nicht rausgeworfen ich muss mir
tatsächlich einmal kurz zur abstimmung
okay aber ihr sollt ja auch gebildet und
so laden wählen könnt ihr nochmal euch
kurz anschauen und dann sind da bilder
drin nee nee nee aber ich glaube für
euch trotzdem verständlich ich gehe eben
abstimmung als er sah dass gleiches
gleich
[Musik]
so genug naja ich kann das buch gar
nicht weiter lesen ja schade vielleicht
wenn du dich gut fühlst würde ich
vielleicht noch ein exemplar irgendwie
raus springen auch das muss gar nicht
braucht kicker was ist die aktuelle der
mann ist ja eher von sie interessiere
mich halt überhaupt nicht für sport aber
ich fand spannender ist als das buch von
friedrich merz verloren
es ist also das ist das ist dann
natürlich mehr zu den typ sie kennen ihn
ja privat also die beschreiben wie kann
man ihn beschreiben friedrich merz ist
jetzt endlich die große dosis lieder
singen ja es können auch andere machen
aber ich schätze ihn sehr als orientiere
gent ich finde er hat auch witz und ja
es wirklich noch lesen lächeln sehen
sehr trockener wird so einfach geht das
mit den mann oder kann der die gar nicht
hoch ist ja wahrscheinlich dass geht das
geht ihr müsst ihr noch eine chance
geben und ich finde friedrich merz ist
ein sehr guter parteivorsitz welt klar
wer inhalte klare linie und haben
linksradikale in der cdu eine chance
also ich sehe das so politiker wie
daniel günther
daniel günther ist ein erfolgreicher
ministerpräsident ich freue mich auch
dass er wiedergewählt wurde hatte super
kampagne gemacht richtig richtig
erfolgreich aber da eine winter wurde
innerhalb der cdu schon genosse günther
immer genannt oder
mich gibt es auch unschöne sprüchen der
welchen keine an wie keine ahnung auf
yamaha ich hab's aktien am tor an
der küste hier aber natürlich in eine
partei gibt es auch mal sprüche über den
einen oder den anderen dabei daniel
günther hat der breite akzeptanz für das
gute wahlergebnis und das finde ich auch
gut wir sind eigentlich fast durch würde
ich sagen ja ich doch ganz nett wenn sie
uns jetzt nochmal zum beruf von
friedrich merz wir wollen noch
überraschen sind ja noch weiter aus groß
denn ich glaube der friedrich merz heute
genauso wie alle anderen im bundestag
jetzt auch noch fleißig kämpfen da
müssen wir weiter gucken ob er einen
termin kriegt man gut dann vielen dank
und werben gags über das alter bei
aktienoptionen wir sind ein paar inhalte
oder sind im auto da haben wir sie
mitnehmen nein das geht auch das geht
auch selbst ich war heute auch in meinem
wahlkreis zurück
aber immer ans tempolimit halten ja ja
ja
ich warte nur auf lutz
da kommt sicher jeden moment wir wollen
ja zusammen die and cars machen
[Musik]
das hat er mir versprochen
deswegen habe ich ihnen auch schon die
hälfte der gage gegeben also es kann
sich nur noch um sekunden handeln
[Musik]